il faut que les personnes maîtrisent
parfaitement le français c'est pas ce
qui est écrit dans l'article 1 C
l'autorisation de séjourner en France au
titre du roupement familiale et délivre
à l'étranger sous réserve qui justifie
au préalable auprès d'autorités
compétente par tout moyen une
connaissance de la langue française lui
permettant au moins de communiquer de
façon élémentaire au moyen d'énoncer
très simple visant à satisfaire les
besoins concrets d'expression familière
et quotidiennees c'est pas parfaitement
et vous dites comment vous faites avec
les les les femmes afghanes enfin les
femmes afghanes pardon mais c'est de la
réunification familiale c'est des
réfugiés c'est pas le regroupement
familial on parle du regroupement
familial il est évident que dans les
pays qui mènent à l'asile et pour lequel
il y a des persécutions on va pas
demander qu'il prennent des cours de
français avant d'accepter une
rémunication familiale il s'agit là bien
de gens qui relèvent du regroupement
familial sur la distinction qui n'a pas
été fait tout à l'heure par le sénateur
Rabier donc je pense qu'il faut pas
caricaturer ce dispositif il est évoqué
par la rapporteur comme étant comme
ayant d'ailleurs déjà existé il a existé
dans depuis novembre 2007 et la majorité
socialiste ne l'avait supprimé qu'en
décembre 2016 ce qui prouve bien qu'on a
pu vivre que les 4/5è du ququen de
Monsieur Hollande avec ce contrat
d'intégration sans que la République ne
se soit effondré puisque vous ne l'avez
supprimé que dans les 6 derniers mois de
la présidence du président du président
Hollande alors ce qui est vrai c'est que
d'autres pays le font en Allemagne il y
a le même dispositif en Allemagne pour
le groupement familial on demande
puisque vous parlez des exemple à
l'étranger que les gens parlent de façon
élémentaire l'allemand ils ont le droit
de présenter trois tests avant le
roupement familial bon c'est un
gouvernement socialiste et vert ils ont
pas j'ai pas eu l'impression qu'ils
avaient dénaturé profondément leur
politique d'intégration en après il y a
des choses qu'on peut améliorer parce
que la seule limite de ce que nous
faisons c'est en effet où est-ce qu'on
apprend c'est cours de français alors
que prévoyait le prê contrat
d'intégration sur lequel s'inspire
j'imagine les dispositions prévues par
la commission des lois B il prévoyait
que lorsqu'on disait non à quelqu'un
parce qu'il avait pas des éléments
élémentaires de langue et ben on devait
lui fournir des cours et d'ailleurs
l'OFI le fait est extrêmement bien
sateur carouci n'est plus là mais il
pour en témoigner pas le travail que
fait l'OFI la question qui se pose c'est
dans les pays qui ne disposent pas de
l'OFI et donc Madame la S madame la
députée euh comment dirais-je pardon
jacie et Laforge avait proposé l'anné
dernière que ce soit possible de le
faire soit de manière numérique ça a été
dit c'est pas vrai partout c'est pas
vrai tout le temps donc c'est forcément
imparfait soit dans les Alliances
françaises euh on peut tout à fait
imaginer retravailler en effet euh
peut-être en rvoyant sur un décret les
dispositions concrètes l'application de
cette disposition pour qu'on voir là où
il y a pas de possibilité de faire des
études en ligne là où il n'y a pas de
possibilité d'avoir accès à l'OFI là où
il y a pas d'alliance française avouez
que c'est quand même peu de pays là où
il y a pas d'asile puisque l'asile
évidemment c'est la réunification
familiale on puisse prévoir peut-être
s'il y a des exceptions au moins des
corrections mais en tout cas il me
semble que ce ce ce ce texte écrit par
la Commission des des lois est frappé du
cour d' B sens c'est gouvernement le
soutient et repousse donc les
amendements de suppression